[Musik]
das bereinigen formel 1 freunde das ist
in diesem sport schnell geht es keine
ganz neue erkenntnis dass es so schnell
geht es vielleicht dann doch wiederum
überraschend ferrari auf platz eins und
zwei nach dem qualifying zum großen
preis von bahrain erklärt vor sebastian
vettel lewis hamilton dritter
teamkollegen valtteri bottas im mercedes
vierter der sieger von melbourne vor
zwei wochen wo das alles ganz anders
aussah wo ferrari chancenlos war
mercedes dominant ja und dann ist da
noch die spannende frage ob das der
startschuss ist für das duell intern bei
ferrari es wurden sicher schon im
vorfeld so seitige dinge über das talent
von schale klerk erzählt erscheint das
durchaus belegen zu können ist jetzt der
zweitjüngste formel 1 pilot der auf die
poleposition bei einem grand prix
gefahren deswegen damals nur vettel
selbst bei seiner allerersten im jahr
2008 damals noch im toro rosso und
erklärt ihnen heute abgehängt deutlich
um fast drei zehntelsekunden
vettel muss im zweiten
qualifikations-abschnitt ein umlauf mehr
machen als geklärt weil er mit dem
ersten
wir fangen im verkehr nicht zufrieden
waren nicht sicher sein konnte überhaupt
weiter zu kommen so fehlt ihnen dann im
letzten abschnitt einen reifensatz denen
er gerne verwendet hätte er hatte also
nur eine chance direkt die hat nicht
gereicht etwas schneller und damit sind
eigentlich für das rennen morgen ist
nicht nur die frage offen ob ferrari
tatsächlich dann auch im rennen mercedes
schlagen kann sondern es ist auch die
frage im raum ob sebastian vettel
tatsächlich die nummer 1 ist bei ferrari
oder ob dort jetzt zwei piloten auf
augenhöhe unterwegs sind
[Musik]